[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with economist
carol malone and the editor of the
courier david clegg they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
april cruel day that's the headline in
the mirror as consumers are hit with a
range of price and tax hikes that amount
to what the paper calls the worst attack
on living standards
the metro leads with news of energy
company websites crashing as customers
try to get their meter readings in
before they're hit by the big price
rises
that's also the angle taken by the
guardian on its front page
the sun that sums it up simply with
these words pain in the gas
the eye says senior conservative mps are
accusing the chancellor of being
politically naive as national insurance
increases
the times reports that britain is
worried that america france and germany
will pressure ukraine into a peace deal
with russia that will make too many
concessions to moscow
the financial times report that the u.s
is dipping into its oil reserves to try
to quell the rise in fuel prices sparked
by the war in ukraine
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch us
and tonight we're joined by congress
carol malone and the editor of the
courier david clegg welcome to you both
let's start with the mirror front page
and their headline
april cruel day as uh all the rice's
coming into force uh tomorrow people are
going to be hit with them well they're
going to be hit in their their pocket
big time
david
yes i think it's a really concerning
time for a lot of people across the uk
at the minute this is something which
has been building slowly we've had
people at my newspaper getting in touch
with us quite regularly over the last
couple of months really concerned about
this cost of living crisis and
the impact it's going to have and i
think especially tomorrow when it just
seems like a few of these things are
coming together and causing real
problems not least the
energy price cap changing and the
seeing bills going up by really eye
watering amounts there's a chap that we
covered in in our paper and is monthly
bills going up from 106 pounds to 400
pounds
uh you know it's like taking on an extra
mortgage so i think i think there's
there's real concern about that and the
political impact of it all is that after
the chancellor's recent statement it
feels like the uk government have not
taken this seriously that there's still
a a lack of recognition of how this is
going to feel at the real brunt and that
and that people who are already
struggling financially are going to be
struggling
even worse and it feels to me like the
government does need to be doing more
about this quite quickly and we're not
really seeing much evidence of that i
know there's some reports in some of the
papers tomorrow morning that
tory backbenchers are worried about this
even one minister being quoted
anonymously in one of the papers saying
that rishi sunak should be doing more so
i think this is a real problem it's
going to have real world impact it plays
into the other issue we're going to be
discussing tonight about the situation
in ukraine and how that affects energy
and gas security and it just feels that
we're in a really turbulent time and
that perhaps the government's response
to that it's not being serious enough as
yet
yes and carol the the mirror follows on
from that that unquoted
conservative
minister um saying act now mr sunak to
do something to prevent the energy bills
going up or to counter that the council
tax national insurance water bills
broadband charges i mean it's it's a
hell of a lot isn't it
i mean that mirror from page sums it all
up really it just lists everything
that's going up for people as you've
just said there council tax more
national insurance water bills broadband
everything is going off tomorrow and it
feels like we've been carrying the
burden for a long time as david said
we've been talking about this but the
truth of it is it hasn't started to hit
people yet it is now going to do that as
of tomorrow and you know sunak has said
today he said in all the papers today
that he couldn't do anything more to
relieve people's pain he said he know he
was
this would be unpopular but he had to be
honest with people but being honest is
all very well and he was talking about
the code of death saying it was 2.3
trillion it's all very well being honest
but that doesn't help people uh you know
who who are literally gonna have to make
choices about food and about whether
they have the lights on and whether they
have the heating on i mean thank god
it's the summer is coming and it might
not be as bad as it would have been in
the winter but we know that even though
energy bills are going to go by 54
now
that is going to be increased again the
cap is going to be increasing by 700 uh
tomorrow so about 1 900 and something
and then they're saying it could be 3
000 by october which is huge
i just don't know how people are gonna
find this extra money and for sunak to
sit there and say there's nothing you
can do you know i
i i it would be crazy to say he could he
could you know stave off the pain for
everyone he can't but it just doesn't
seem to me like he's done enough at the
moment no one in living memory i can't
remember ever at a time like this where
the bills went up to such an extent and
by such massive percentages this is this
is the the worst energy shock in living
memory so um and you know it's
interesting
you were talking about what they were
saying about after today there was one
mp said his chances of being leader are
gone now he's like the golden boy has
gone to nobody's boy no one is
interested in sue lack and they're very
angry with them especially a lot of
senior tories david would you agree with
that because the rate of inflation is
expected to reach a 40-year high of at
least 8.7 percent do you agree that uh
rishi sunak's
hopes of perhaps one day being prime
minister have evaporated
i'm not sure i'd go that far because we
said that many times about boris johnson
and it didn't turn out that way but but
i think i think certainly
there's certainly a sense that his stock
has fallen dramatically if you're if you
remember at the height of the pandemic
uh when he was being lauded for the uh
you know to help out scheme it feels
like there's been a str you know a
definitive shift since then and i do
think if the the front story on the
metro tomorrow which is talking about
just the absolute panic that we're
seeing from people that are at the sharp
end of this trying to go online onto
their energy provider and
put in their most up-to-date meter
reading so that they don't get charged
more for for for gas that they've used
before the price changed the energy
companies seem to have had a
catastrophic failure in allowing the
technology to work on that but i think
what really brought that home to me
today was i was picking my kids up from
school earlier and it was the talk of
the playground that you need to do this
get your energy reading across by the
end of the day this had really cut
through to everyone because there is
such concern about
the uh
the cost and how this is going to affect
everyone's everyone's bills so i think
the fact that that we're seeing that
type of situation where people are so
concerned about their energy bills
they're crashing websites that uh
suggest that the the you know the
current uk government in particular the
chancellor their response has not been
adequate it has not been up to the the
sense of gravity and seriousness which
the public certainly feel about it so i
would i would agree absolutely carol
that that is boring to have a
longer-term uh political implication
especially when there's been
it's interesting david that today uh all
the big energy companies were trying to
to to blame money expert martin lewis
yeah i saw that they had to file their
their meter readings today so that the
ng companies wouldn't charge in the new
prices for energies that already use the
idea that they're blaming martin luther
it's farcical these companies knew today
was coming four months they have known
they should have got their houses in
order to prepare they should have known
that customers were going to be wanting
their attention into today and they're
just not ready these companies are
really keen to take our money but
they're not keen to help us and i
completely agree with you you know this
this rush today shows the terror that
people are feeling about what's to come
i mean it is it is terrifying you
mentioned a bill of one of your readers
before one of our bills has gone from
190 a month to 500 and something a month
that's the bit i mean that's a huge rise
the other thing about the energy
companies is since that their systems
went into meltdown they've been very
quick this evening or later earlier
earlier this afternoon to say there will
be more time don't worry about it it
doesn't happen to happen tonight so
they're gonna have to be very careful to
get their systems in check now so that
people don't lose out further because of
their technological meltdown yeah it is
very true though that people are
absolutely terrified because they have
known for some time in lots of whatsapp
groups and emails have been going around
saying do your meter reading do your
meter reading but they've left it to the
last possible day because i think that
the reality has dawned on them that this
is happening and what's 22 million
customers we'll see an increase the
majority will see their bills rise to to
just under 2 000 pounds a year
overnight people are thrown into debt
i think a lot of people didn't realize
that they didn't think about the media
martin luther has told them to do it
he's the guy who's on the side of the
consumer and he's the one who said do it
you know do it before midnight tonight i
i think people thought they didn't have
to do that but when you think about it
especially they do because the energy
companies the idea that they're going to
be able to do it all right if people
don't get that veto victims in time no
we can't trust them together right so i
hope i hope lots of people have today i
i feel like that while i was octopus and
they've said there's if they've got a
few day you've got a few days grace
before they will start charging you
on the politics sorry go ahead
well i just i'd only seen the sun front
page there as you flashed it up on
screen because it was just coming in as
we're we're on air but i i suspect it
will strike terror into the heart of the
uk government
and particularly rishi sunak that not
only is the mur a traditional labor
supporting paper uh going so heavy on
this with such a powerful front page but
the sun is saying exactly the same thing
both the mass market newspapers in the
in the country realize that their
readers are going to be
most concerned about this and it i would
i would be pretty concerned about that
if i was the uk government yes there's
some they're paying in the gas their
their headline uh on screen for you but
the eye also uh concentrating on the the
anger that's being leveled towards uh
rishi sunak because this living crisis
really has actually as the headline says
hit home today
carol i mean you know i i
in some sense yes i think he has to help
you know people on lower incomes
and it isn't just going to be it's
because it's not just i mean there was
talk the other day that benefits should
be increased it's not just the people on
benefits who are going to be suffering
here you know the working poor are going
to be suffering the you know middle
classes are going to be suffering
they're only the very rich will not
suffer in this crisis you know he soonax
argument is he's got a 2.3 trillion debt
to sort out and he's saying you know
that there will be uh perhaps more help
come october but you know a lot of
people might not make it till october i
mean i think that one of the things i
saw is that
people are going to be in in in fuel
poverty so like 2.5 million people in
fuel poverty you know every kind of
energy property and by october another
2.5 million so that's five million
people who are not going to be able to
make ends meet with the money that you
know the money that they're earning and
the bills that they're getting it's it
is
nothing like this since the 50s nothing
as as big and as severe as this since
the 50s and it's striking terror into
the hearts of of everyone yeah
absolutely terrifying but the chance of
saying that he can't help
more people um at the moment at least
thank you both we're going to take a
break um coming up
the front page of the financial times
we're going to be diving into that biden
orders record oil stockpile release in
effort to quell fuel costs don't go
anywhere
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me carol malone and
david clegg welcome back to both of you
let's um have a look at the ft
front page by norda's record oil
stockpile release an effort to quell
fuel costs and this is the new release
of a million barrels a day by far the
the biggest announcer so far to to
combat um the lack of uh stocks carol
take us into this one
um
well yes i mean we know what's happening
you know putin today
um has said that he will he will block
uh our gas supplies if we don't
start paying him in rubles he wants to
shore up the ruble it's collapsing
although his economy is collapsing and
he's telling what he calls uh unfriendly
states that they're going to have to
open bank accounts and pay him in
is trying to stop that you know it's
this is
it's very a lot of western countries
have said they're not going to do that
but it's dangerous because you know
a lot of commodities are bought in
dollars and in euros and because putin's
dollars have been frozen he can't use it
but this is damaging both this is
damaging to the dollar because it's
endangering the dominance of the dollar
in the markets and so it's it's it's
quite a big thing to do it's quite a
terrifying thing to do you know boris is
already warning and lots of countries
europe um not to cave in with these
sanctions because there are parts of
europe that are that are very very
reliant on russian gas germany being the
biggest i think it was in 2020
germany got 60 percent of its gas
imports from russia uh last year it was
55
from russia and europe as a whole
is it it has the it's the largest
important of natural gas in the world
and the largest share of that comes from
russia so you know russia really has us
over a barrel literally a barrel which
is which is terrifying you know we we
only get five percent the uk only gets
five percent of this gas from russia so
we won't have a problem with supply but
we will have a problem with prices as
the global com demand for it gets bigger
so it will affect us germany is
panicking now italy is panicking now
they get half of their gas supplies from
russia um so yeah it's terrifying for
the world you know it makes you think
what's gonna happen russia sorry germany
have said their their economy minister
today called robert hardback he said
that um that germany wouldn't be uh
independent of russia and until 2024 so
what are they going to do in the
meantime they're putting they're they're
rationing their people now um but you
know how long are the supplies they've
got going to last if putin turns their
tap off
yes um and it's i know you say five
percent um the uk we're not as reliant
as as germany say but overall it is
going to affect globally and with
america dipping into their
their reserves it's the the drawdown
that would take the reserve to its
lowest level since 1984. so this is
quite a gamble for uh biden who already
is um quite unpopular because of the
rise in in fuel costs david
yes i mean i think this is a major
challenge for politicians across the
globe because energy security is now
so important it ties into the other big
uh political issue of climate change and
the reliance on oil and gas that
obviously has a domestic dimension uh in
the uk and indeed in scotland about
north sea oil and how we exploit that in
future
i think actually though the
vladimir putin's move here is in some
ways being exposed as a little bit of a
bluff i think he's all there's already
some sign that he's that he's
backtracking today that there will be
some work around that this may be more
about being able to talk tough
domestically i mean he is extremely
reliant on that money it is a symbiotic
relationship that he had that we that we
have with russia in regards to oil and
gas which is
really quite dangerous and from the west
perspective being able to wean ourselves
off that would be the the wisest and
safest course of action but it feels
like there will be a workaround
especially because if we think back uh
the oil continued to flow even in the
darkest days of the cold war in the last
century so
it feels like it feels like some of the
signals we're seeing uh this evening or
perhaps the putin is backing away from
that but i think the the political
implications for uh national leaders
across europe and indeed the west is
that there's a very dangerous and
unstable character with a large share of
the globe's oil supply
and gas supply and that that is that is
a major concern so it brings us on i
think a little bit to some of the other
stories we're seeing today about uh
whether ukraine will come under
international pressure to uh go into a
peace deal too early because if you're
as carl has just outlined there if
you're if you're germany or indeed most
of the european union here are very
dependent on oil
uh you're you're you're concerned by
this
my suspicion is it's a toothless threat
but it's still a threat that's going to
cause a lot of worry uh in in the in the
corridors of par in europe
just change the subject to oh go ahead
carol
i was just going to say this talk now
because because in places like germany
and italy where you know the gas is
going to be there's talk of going back
to coal power and and nuclear power you
know germany is is really opposed to
nuclear power has been since the 70s but
you know if there's you know and i can
see lots of other countries going back
we have run out of time but you'll be
able to uh
extemporize at the 11 o'clock hour see
you in a moment thank you both